[Music]
we're here with Lanier at the workspace
booth and she's going to tell us about
how workspace is using AI to better
productivity and creativity
hello I'm Lanier I work for the
workspace launch programs team and I'm
going to walk you all through a demo of
how you can use duet AI to supercharge
your productivity the way this demo is
going to go is we're going to follow
Quinn Quinn is a marketing manager at a
company called symbol and we're going to
see how she uses these features to go
throughout her game through her
responsibilities so the first part of
this demo is with Gmail I'm sure we've
all woken up to a bunch of emails we
really don't have time to read through
all of them now using duet AI you can
summer get a summary of all of those
emails so these 25 unread emails
Quinn is able to ask you an AI please
summarize information she gets this
summary right here and in the summary
she learns that a product that she's
getting to Market in South America the
launch date is getting pushed up so now
that she knows this there's action items
that she has to take and she is going to
ask you an AI to reply to the email and
in the email response she's able to ask
you at AI to distribute key action items
for herself and for her teammates so she
gets the email she's ready to send it
and she inserts it into her Gmail
so right there now she has this amazing
email that she sent to her team and
something that would have taken quite
hours reading through all those emails
responding now she's able to do in a few
minutes with Dua AI
all right so now she's gonna use do it
Ai and Google slides and this is all
about helping her do something when she
doesn't have a lot of time as we learned
from the beginning she's under time
crunch the product is getting put to
Market a lot faster so she needs to
build a deck but rather than starting
from scratch she's able to use existing
content to help build a new Google slide
so right here she's asking do at AI to
generate a slide based off of a sales
training plan document so duet AI uses
the content from that document and
builds her a slide
all right so she sees the image that Dua
AI chose for her and on second thought
she kind of wants something that's a
little bit more specific to the South
American market so she's able to ask you
at AI to create an image of a coffee
farm with a Brazilian flag flowing very
specific very original and Dua AI is
able to create four different options
for her and now she decides this is the
one I want to use and she inserts it
directly into the Slime so next Gwen is
gonna go into her sales meeting she's
gonna be meeting in the southwest team
and she wants to make a good impression
for them so she is going to use Dua AI
to generate a custom background for the
meeting all right so she's going to
describe the image she wants she wants a
coffee shop with a painting of a golden
trumpet tree very specific again and Dua
AI is able to generate really great
options for her
so after she picks the style she says
create and in under 20 seconds Dua AI is
able to generate some options for her
and now she picks this one the sir
favorites you can see it's her
background for the beating
ready to join
so I'm sure we've all been on really
long meetings and there's a lot of
things being said people are throwing
out action items but maybe no one is
taking notes so now you are able to have
a meeting summary of everything that was
discussed during that meeting there's
going to be action items in the notes
and this is going to be really useful if
you need to send this out to someone
maybe who missed the meeting or they
need a recap of what was discussed in
the meeting and that's all going to be
generated for you in this Google doc and
one of the action items from the meeting
was for Quinn herself to create an FAQ
so she's able to ask Dua AI to create
the FAQ for her and she inserts it
directly into her Google Docs and
finally as the marketing manager Gwen is
responsible for putting together a blog
post and she needs to pull it together
quickly she doesn't have a lot of time
and so she is going to use
um some previous content that she's
written from a US market blog post but
asked do it AI to tailor it for the
South American market so she's able to
say write a blog post based on this U.S
blob content for the South American
audience and she wants it to have
customer references so she can put local
quotes in this new blog post and she
asked you and I to do that and within a
few seconds it's able to generate this
Coast for her and she needs to take it a
step further she has to create a
marketing campaign so now she's going to
ask you at AI to create headlines for
ads and she needs five headlines with
under 30 characters
and it's going to generate these ads
based on the blog content so just like
that in under 20 seconds she has these
five amazing headlines so she was able
to make those marketing assets really
quickly and this is just a snapshot of
the things that you can use with duet AI
thank you so much for sharing all of
this with us is there anything else any
hidden gems any special things that you
think are interesting to share I would
say the best part is that customers can
try this out now for free with a free
trial if you go to Google and you type
in workspace do AI free trial you can
try all of these amazing features out
today amazing we'll probably put those
links in the description so make sure to
check them out thank you so much Lanier
and have a great time at the rest of the
conference
thank you
[Music]